and just like asking about some open
world uh a very different one is the
world of
either Grand Theft Auto or Red Dead
Redemption both love I would put GTA 3
Grand Theft Auto 3 up there with the
landmark kind of Usher in the open world
when that comes out on the PlayStation 2
even though there was GTA one and two
this was an all new thing with the
mobster storytelling uh the device 3D
version I guess it was it was then Vice
City is kind of a fast follow which uh
could be my favorite one
um
I loved all the Grand Theft Auto's think
they're really phenomenally well made
games same with red dead I think Red
Dead Redemption one
could be my favorite story
like I highly recommend finishing that
game so you like both the story you like
the grittiness of that because they have
they have a bit of the
like I guess if you like to fall Fallout
as the humor the I don't know I don't
know what it is it's the light-hearted
humor of it but also the brutality of
human nature is in there too but it's
like uh
and also some of the fun they create
with the music when you drive and stuff
like that they they create they create a
world there's a tone they do there's a
very strong there's a very strong tone
um you know the satire on the world is
just so well done the gameplay is great
um I think they've just done a
a phenomenal job